foreign
s the interrelatedness between sleep and
Alzheimer's disease I wanted to just hop
right into it I have Alzheimer's disease
on both sides of my family and have seen
this
up close and personal
what are the connections if any between
those two
yeah I think this is perhaps one of the
most exciting areas to have emerged in
sleep science over the past maybe five
or six years or so and I'm just taking a
step back of course everyone knows that
Alzheimer's disease it's a form of
dementia typified by memory impairment
and memory Decline and we've learned
that there are at least two protein
pathological culprits that contribute to
Alzheimer's disease one of those is
called beta amyloid which is a sticky
toxic protein that builds up in the
brain and the second is called Tau
protein so coming back to your question
how are those things related to sleep
well it's probably unfolded gosh maybe
in a three part or even four part story
and I'm very nervous to say four part
and you'll see why in terms of that in
just a second but the three main parts
were correlation
causation and then mechanism
and so
early on what we started to discover is
that individuals who reported sleeping
six hours or less across their lifespan
had a significantly higher risk of
developing high amounts of this toxic
beta amyloid and also Tau protein in the
brain then we discovered that two Sleep
Disorders both insomnia and sleep apnea
which is a condition of sort of heavy
snoring sometimes you stop breathing
it's clinically diagnosed both of those
conditions were associated with a higher
risk of both Alzheimer's pathology but
also the transition to early stages and
ultimately the transition to full-blown
Alzheimer's disease
in fact I think there was a recent
meta-analysis looking at maybe it was
over 27 different studies and what they
found is that people who had sleep
problems during the lifespan were about
3.78 times more likely to develop the
early stages of Alzheimer's disease in a
premature fashion
so those were these epidemiological
studies those are simply correlational
they're associational they don't prove
you know causality
so correlation then went in search of
causation
and what we've discovered we and other
individuals some people working in
animal cities we work in humans
but across species what we found is that
if you just bribe individuals of a night
of sleep or even if you deprive them
selectively of just their deep non-rem
sleep across a single night then the
next day we can see an immediate and
significant increase in beta amyloid and
Tau protein circulating in the
bloodstream circulating in what we call
the cerebral spinal fluid of the brain
which is this a fluid that bathes the
brain and also using special pet
scanning images we've been able to see
that same buildup of amyloid within the
brain itself
and in fact there was a recent study
that looked at this these signals of
metabolic
sort of detritus in the brain and what
they found is that after one night of
sleep deprivation even a full recovery
night of sleep was not sufficient to
downgrade those metabolic toxins that
have been building up in the brain
so
so in that sense it was a demonstration
causally that you can remove this thing
called sleep or even selectively excise
different types of sleep and you can
manipulate the amount of Alzheimer's
protein in the brain the next day
so that was the causal evidence
causation then wanted sort of you know a
mechanism and
perhaps here in some ways that you can
reverse engineer it or you can flip it
on its head if that's the bad that
happens if I take sleep away from you
then what is it about sleep when we get
it that de-escalates your Alzheimer's
disease pathology risk and this comes on
to a series of discoveries the principal
person underlying this was a wonderful
scientist at the University of Rochester
called Macon nedergaard and she was
working in mice and she made three
stunning discoveries in my mind at least
the first is that she discovered that
the brain has a cleansing system
now it sounds strange you know many
people would think well it must have
because the body has a cleansing system
and everyone's familiar with it it's
called the lymphatic system but we
didn't think that the brain had its own
cleansing system she discovered it and
it's called the glymphatic system
and it's it's named by the way that way
because of the cells that make it up
these they're called glial cells they're
a different form of brain cell we've got
neurons and we've got glial cells and
it's the glial cells that make up this
network of this cleansing system so that
was the first discovery that she made
if that wasn't amazing enough she then
found two more related discoveries what
she then found was that that cleansing
mechanism in the brain is not always
switched on in high flow volume across
the 24-hour period of course the 24-hour
clock face instead it was particularly
when those mice fell asleep and when
they went into deep non-rapid eye
movement sleep or non-rem sleep
um the other stage of sleep being rap
and I moved and sleep but it was during
deep non-rem sleep when that pulsing
cleansing system kicked into high gear
and so
that was then her sort of shift to then
say well what are those things that the
brain is cleansing during deep sleep and
this is what brings us on to or back to
Alzheimer's disease two of the pieces of
the metabolic byproducts that were being
washed away by deep non-rem sleep at
night were beta amyloid and Tau protein
these two culprits associated with
Alzheimer's disease and scientists in
Boston a couple of years ago and we've
now replicated this in humans as well
identified a similar cleansing mechanism
in humans using special MRI scans
so that was evidence almost from a
biochemical perspective and this is
probably slightly hyperbolic to say a
mindful of it but biochemically perhaps
it's true which is
we were starting to understand that
wakefulness was low-level brain damage
and sleep was your sanitary salvation
it was almost like a good night's sleep
clean that was a power cleanse for the
brain that was happening during sleep
but this started to explain why you got
maybe this trajectory of Alzheimer's
disease it went all the way back to the
associational studies so now we can
understand why night after night if
you're not getting the sleep that you
need you're not cleansing the brain of
the pathology and it's it's not vast
that builds up after one night of sleep
and I don't want to scare anyone here
and I've you know I'm sure I'll probably
get some concerned voices I'm not trying
to make anyone nervous about a bad night
of sleep and the next day you've
guaranteed your Alzheimer's disease fate
that's not at all the situation but it
did help us understand that night after
night if you're not cleansing the brain
it becomes like compounding interest on
a loan that it continues to escalate
time and time again night after night
and then if that wasn't depressing
enough we then went on to make a further
discovery that it's a vicious cycle
that Alzheimer's disease pathology those
proteins do not build up in the brain
homogeneously they don't build up in all
areas of the brain equally
and what we discovered is that the parts
of the brain that start to get attacked
by Alzheimer's disease early on are
unfortunately the same regions of the
brain that generate deep non-rem sleep
the same stage of sleep that's
associated with the cleansing isn't it
just and so now we'd found this vicious
spiral that if you don't get enough
sleep each night you get more of that
Alzheimer's build up the more that
builds up the less the brain is capable
of generating deep sleep the less deep
sleep the more that builds up what are
the structures involved with the
production of that deep non-rem sleep
it's essentially a network of brain
regions constellation exactly but one of
if you look at it with brain scans or
electrical recordings one of the main
epicenters in fact probably the
principal epicenter that generates this
deep sleep is a part of the frontal lobe
particularly the middle part of your
frontal lobe so if you sort of put your
finger just above your nose and slide it
up about an inch and a half that's the
middle part of what we call the
prefrontal cortex or the medial
prefrontal cortex that is a deep sleep
generating center for the brain you get
principle dominance of your deep sleep
in that part of the brain and then these
big brain waves they Splash on the brain
and they actually wave across the brain
from the front of the brain to the back
from the front to the back it's this
beautiful mechanism that we can see this
this sort of wave of these deep slow
brain waves it's amazing and so that was
a part of the brain that showed these
Alzheimer's attacks early on and it's
the same region that is generating the
deep sleep in adults so that was the
demonstration of mechanism that helped
us perhaps go back and explain the
associations then
perhaps the the fourth ingredient that
I'm really you know I'm almost nervous
to say it because it's the most
dangerous of all things which is the
suggestion of Hope and I don't mean to
make false sort of promises here but
what I find interesting is that unlike
many of the other features that we know
are associated with Alzheimer's disease
for example changes in the physical
structure of the brain or even the blood
flow dynamics of the brain those are
very difficult to treat right now and
Medicine doesn't have any good wholesale
approaches but if sleep is a missing
piece in the explanatory puzzle of aging
and Alzheimer's disease then maybe we
can do something about it sleep is a
modifiable factor
and we've been looking at this in the
laboratory we've
been approaching this not by using
sleeping pills and we may come on to
those things they seem to be more blunt
to instruments that don't produce
necessarily naturalistic sleep but we've
been developing some technology it's
called direct current brain stimulation
which which sounds like the stuff of
Science Fiction it's actually science
fact where you apply these pasty head
and you insert a small amount of voltage
into the brain and it's so small by the
way that you typically don't feel it but
it has a measurable impact
and early studies demonstrated that if
you apply this stimulation during sleep
as if you're sort of singing in time
with those deep sleep brain waves not
only can you amplify the size of those
deep sleep brain waves but in doing so
people were able to almost double the
amount of memory benefit that you get
from sleep
so so the question then was could we
translate that same affordable
potentially portable technology into
older adults and could we restore back
some deep sleep and sort of Salvage
aspects of learning and memory function
that's that's one of our goals and we've
I've been developing this and have a
startup company that's public now that's
looking at this to me though that is
probably not really where I'll
ultimately be excited about because
thinking about late stage Alzheimer's
disease when the brain has been
pathologized that much it's very
difficult to salvage
I am much more interested in shifting
from a model in Alzheimer's of late
stage treatment to mid-life prevention
because to me if I look at the Sleep
data that's when you start to see the
Great Depression of your deep sleep it's
bloody depressing I know I'm an
incredibly depressing person but if you
look it's in your mid to late 30s that
we start to see the decline in deep
sleep
so could I intervene in midlife and
start sort of pushing back against the
decline of deep sleep and in doing so
could we bend the arrow of Alzheimer's
disease risk down on itself
so that's so sort of shifting from a
model of late stage sikka to a model of
mid-life health care I think that's
probably a much more reasonable approach